The critics have spoken, and there's an overwhelming
consensus—Lady Bird is good.
The movie is so good, in fact, that not a
single one of the 170 reviewers registered
with Rotten Tomatoes made a negative judgment
about the film.
As a result, not only does the movie boast
an impressive 100% score on Rotten Tomatoes,
but the sheer volume of positive reviews has
led the movie to become the highest-rated
movie ever in the website's 19-year history.
"That we know of yet."
The winsome story of a Catholic teen's coming-of-age
in 2002, Lady Bird stars Saoirse Ronan as
Christine "Lady Bird" McPherson, a 17-year-old
girl in Sacramento who navigates life, love
and family drama on her way out of high school
and onward to New York.
The movie's unprecedented success with reviewers
since its premiere on September 1st has resulted
in the dethroning of the site's previously
highest-rated movie, Toy Story 2, which was
released in 1999.
That movie notched a 100% score as well, but
only 163 reviews were recorded toward that
rating.
"Somebody do something!"
It was a marvelous run for the Pixar classic,
but the crowning of a new champion is an absolute
triumph for filmmaker Greta Gerwig, a 34-year-old
writer and actress making her directorial
debut.
It's hard to imagine how she could've made
a better first impression.
Previously, Gerwig gained notice for co-writing
and starring in Frances Ha and Mistress America,
as well as her recent appearances in 20th
Century Women and Jackie as a performer.
Ronan, around whose performance the film revolves,
will be seen next year starring in the films
On Chesil Beach, The Seagull, and Mary Queen
of Scots.
"What if this IS the best version?"
Gerwig said of her record-setting accomplishment:
"This is completely amazing and so incredibly
appreciated by the entire team that made Lady
Bird."
"We put our heart and souls into this movie,
and the last step of this deeply collaborative
art form of filmmaking is giving the film
to the audience and the film critics."
"That there has been such a warm reception
is a dream come true.
Thank you to everyone who has seen the film
and has written about it so thoughtfully.
We are all on cloud nine and using our tomato
emoji more than we ever thought possible."
Who'd have guessed that such a sweet little
indie drama from a debut director could achieve
so much.
"Who the f--- is on top their first time?"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!